friday july 2nd edition hiatus style pft
live pft pm i'm back one day after
having
that rogue vampire wisdom tooth removed
it was
incredibly easy i worry about everything
i never worry about the things i should
worry about those are the
things that tend to bite me in the ass
the things i obsess over
usually work out well and the wisdom
tooth removal worked out
very well feeling very good no swelling
that i'm aware of maybe you are
everything is fine on the inside it was
just one not all four i can't imagine
getting rid of all four
so uh off we go back sooner than i
thought i would be
and i picked a hell of a day to have a
wisdom tooth removed because
i had to spend a lot of time dealing
with the analysis the assessment and the
aftermath of the news that broke
yesterday that
following a year-long investigation
washington football team
imposing penalties sort of against
washington owner daniel snyder for
workplace issues that as i mentioned had
been
investigated for more than a year
initially it was schneider who hired
beth wilkinson
to come in and investigate the situation
there
then after one of the stories broke i
believe it was the story
about the cheerleader videos where the
outtakes were being
collected allegedly sent to senior
management
allegedly that was the moment where
the league took over the investigation
that was started by
beth wilkinson well now it's over the
commissioner has reached a conclusion
and
yesterday the news was announced
not a coincidence frankly that it was
the day before
the friday of july 4 weekend if they had
waited until today
it would have been too damn obvious and
i've noticed that trend
recently from the nfl once they started
using
weekends in the summer as bad news dumps
and started getting
called out for it i'm not aware of
anyone who would have
called them out for that they started
moving sometimes to thursday so it
wouldn't be quite so obvious so this
week is thursday because it would have
been really obvious
if they had done it today and frankly
when you consider the fourth landing on
a sunday a lot of people aren't working
on friday anyway
this week so yesterday the perfect time
to announce the penalties and other
consequences of that investigation
the commissioner made general findings
and they are
damning findings of a workplace culture
that
had claims of sexual harassment bullying
of
subordinate employees detachment from
ownership
dan snyder is one of the owners who
hadn't in the past been in the building
on a regular basis well you better trust
the people who are there
and you better know that they are people
who aren't going to do things they
shouldn't be doing now
snyder i think was around senior
management enough to have an
inkling of what was going on and
maybe it was a reflection of who he is
and how he is
but we just don't know i'm going to get
to that all we know is the general
conclusion not the specific just the
general and the general conclusions
are very very damning the general
conclusions
point to a significant penalty
and then that's where the penalties come
in a 10 million dollar fine
which some have described as pocket
change for a billionaire
10 million is still 10 million but look
i i agree it's not a huge portion of
daniel snyder's net worth
it's not a huge portion of the value of
the team
but it is a significant fine the biggest
fine ever issued
by the nfl on top of that he'll be
paying what i'm told is upwards of seven
million dollars
for the beth wilkinson investigation
that was known he was going to do that
anyway
even if he'd been exonerated he was
paying that bill
he started the process by hiring her the
league took it over
if the end result had been dan snyder is
blameless the team did nothing wrong
snyder would still be paying beth
wilkinson's fees and 7 million isn't all
that
out of line when you consider that over
150 different people were
interviewed as part of this process
snyder himself interviewed twice
now the other penalty which
technically isn't a penalty i think it
was a negotiated outcome
the voluntary stepping aside by snyder
from the day-to-day operations his wife
tanya snyder who just a few days ago
became co-ceo
and co-owner and i was told last night
by a very good source not to be confused
with my usual bad sources
that that was directly motivated by what
they knew was coming
that was the reason it was done i
speculated the other day about estate
planning and that may be part of it too
that may be an incidental benefit
but tonya snyder was put in that role 48
hours
before she took over the reins of the
team
voluntarily from her husband now
is it really voluntary again i think it
was negotiated i think if he hadn't
voluntarily done it
he would have been suspended the league
the benefit they get is they don't have
to suspend him they don't get themselves
into a potential fight
we know that daniel snyder fairly
litigious
back in 2017 when jerry richardson found
himself in a similar
situation with the panthers he just
handed him the keys to the car before
anyone tried to take it from him
they didn't have to deal with richardson
fighting anyone he was ready to sell the
team he didn't have any
kids that he wanted to bequeath the team
to he was ready to move on
snyder would have fought because snyder
was determined to to give
the washington football team to his
children he would have fought tooth and
nail
if there had been a suspension or
something along the lines of he must
sell
the team so voluntarily air quotes
voluntarily stepping aside for a period
of months and there's an interesting ps
to that
last night mark maske the washington
post reported
that snyder can't resume his day-to-day
control of the team until the
commissioner roger goodell
approves it i got some pushback from
that
from some people in the know and i said
hey it's not my report
we're just passing along what mark maske
reported and yeah it's
my analysis of that
fact that supports my belief that this
was negotiated
and my position has been pretty simple
unless masky
retracts his report or someone goes on
the record specifically roger goodell or
daniel snyder and says that that report
is incorrect
not changing our story our story is what
mark maske's story is
until it's retracted by him or refuted
not by somebody who's trying to tell me
that it's false without attaching a name
to it i want a quote
from roger goodell i want a quote from
daniel snyder
before i change our official story that
daniel schneider will not resume
day-to-day operations
of the team not resume representation of
the team at league meetings until
the commissioner allows it at the core
of all of this
is the issue of transparency or lack
thereof
and we kind of sensed it was moving in
this direction
that at the end of the day the report
generated by beth wilkinson
would not be made available as all other
major reports involving
major nfl scandals have been made
available in recent years
back at the bounty scandal there was a
ton of transparency they had mary jo
white respected
public servant lawyer agency head they
hired her to come in and explain
all of this to reporters even though i
have real issues
about the accuracy explanation they had
transparency
the bullying scandal the first time we
ever heard the name ted wells 2013 he
was hired
did a full investigation prepared a
meticulous report
confidential information and their
sensitive allegations we still saw it
deflategate 140 pages ted wells again
full transparency we have seen
transparency over and over
again this one no transparency this one
the report won't be made available and
the reason the report won't be made
available
there is no report no written report
generated by beth wilkinson oral report
to the nfl nothing in writing
now you avoid anyone leaking it
if you don't have a written report and i
suspect that's why there is no written
report
the argument the nfl made yesterday
during a conference call that i think
beth wilkinson should have been part of
frankly they tapped lisa friel on the
shoulder to read off talking points that
in my opinion were crafted by general
counsel jeff pasch
didn't get a whole lot of information it
was some filibustering
and it was very basic broad brush stuff
well why isn't there a report made
available for us to scrutinize
well these are delicate matters we were
told and it's hard to get people to come
forward
so you have to make things confidential
or they won't come forward
well that's fine but there are ways to
protect people
who have come forward without burying
the facts
on which the findings against the team
and snyder were based
you can just change names how hard is
that
jane doe one jane doe two jane doe
three jane doe 150
everyone who spoke to beth wilkinson i
know not all 150 of them were people
making accusations
but all the ones who made accusations
whether it's 40 50 whatever the number
you don't have to give your name if you
don't want to you just don't we won't
use any names we'll make it impossible
to figure out who any of these people
are because we'll use none of the names
in the report
the names don't matter the people matter
but for the purposes of determining
whether and to what extent punishment
should be imposed on the team
the names are irrelevant it's the
behaviors that cry out for
more information for those of us who
would react
and demand more than what ultimately
was levied against the team and against
snyder and that's really
the bottom line here people have argued
that the league
is protecting dan snyder well they're
not protecting him because they like
him i know enough people in ownership
circles to know he's not particularly
popular
he's not particularly powerful he's not
particularly respected
but they're protecting him because for
some of them
and i'm not going to name names because
i don't know names i just know
circumstances you don't want to have the
standard
that gets crafted for daniel snyder
potentially applied
to you you may be sitting on the porch
of a glass house
sipping a chris sims pina colada
you don't want those stones coming back
your way and it's very simple
once people realize the impact of
accusations like this the way you can
take down the king you can knock the
emperor off his horse
you can do that with these accusations
these other guys are going to worry
we're going to be the next ones to be
accused and what if i'm wrongly accused
how do i
defend myself how do i deal with this i
don't want to be cancelled i don't want
to deal with these issues
so they go easy on snyder he doesn't
even get suspended
he's not forced to sell the team i
firmly believe
that if the facts on which the ultimate
conclusions were based
were made available for public scrutiny
there would ultimately be no choice
for the nfl to force daniel snyder to
sell the team
and if this goes by weeks months and at
some point
there's a document that's leaked from
beth wilkinson's office or somewhere
that has that information you know like
that video that we saw from tmz in
september of 2014
it's going to create a major scandal for
the nfl now i don't know how reliable
any of the information will be
a video is undeniable paperwork they can
say this is false this is fabricated
this isn't real whatever remember when
there was a tentative
set of recommendations that was leaked
to 1067 the fan in dc and
and it was all shouted down so i i think
they could deal with this better than
they dealt with the ray rice video
but you know the example that i gave
last night i know they're two different
contexts altogether
but there won't even be a ray rice video
here because the nfl has basically put a
bag over the camera
by not having a report created and they
avoid
what would be i believe ultimately a
decision
that dana schneider would have to sell
the team which could become
decisions that others down the road have
to sell the team if they face similar
allegations
and if some way somehow the truth comes
out about this later
and roger goodell's still the
commissioner but he's going to have
some worries like the worries he had
back in the month of september 2014
after that video came out all right
plenty of other things happening in the
national football league today is the
day
for anyone who wants to opt out for the
2021 season to do so
other than players who have signed their
most recent contracts
after october 1 of 2020 unless those
players have since been diagnosed with a
higher risk condition that puts them in
jeopardy
of a serious consequence from covet now
for those who
already had contracts in place before
october 1
of 2020 they can opt out for any reason
the ones
who either opted out last year or have
developed post october 1
health conditions they get a 350 000
stipend
anyone else eligible to uh to opt out
and sign a contract before october one
they don't get a stipend
but you can opt out for any reason and
that's why there's been speculation
maybe aaron rodgers will do it he would
save over 20 million dollars
if he doesn't i'm told it's highly
unlikely that he'll do it deshaun watson
there's been speculation that he'll do
it
highly unlikely that he'll do it i think
the only guy to watch today
frankly is a guy like cole beasley
whether it's beasley or someone else
somebody who refuses to get vaccinated
who
resents the fact that there's two sets
of rules and doesn't want to be subject
to the 2020 protocol while
most of his teammates are living like
it's 2019.
i could see a guy who is very
anti-vaccine
and is very upset about the protocols
that will apply to him on an enhanced
basis saying i'm just going to take the
year off i'll see you next year
that could happen i've heard nothing to
suggest that any one player will
but at some point between now and 4 p.m
eastern on friday that lightning could
strike and there could be
one or more players who decide to opt
out for 20 21
my guess is the over under 0.5 i'll take
the under i don't think anybody's going
gonna do it
another thing that made its way through
the day before
the friday of july four weekend
news dump the ota violations by not one
not two but three teams cowboys
49ers jaguars and the fines were
significant hundred thousand dollars for
the cowboys and the 49ers
50 000 for coach mike mccarthy and kyle
shanahan respectively
and for the jaguars a 200 000 fine plus
one hundred thousand
for urban meyer the meyer situation not
surprising
a new coach with no nfl experience
bringing his system his style his way of
doing things
to the nfl level and the fact that meyer
and i know there's reports about what
prompted it look he got fined a hundred
grand
i have a feeling this doesn't just
wasn't one drill that got out of hand
i i think to get to a hundred thousand
dollars for you and 200 000 for the team
there's some stuff going on that
shouldn't be happening
and this is what happens when a lifetime
college coach who's used to running
everything
not being told you can't do this you
can't do this
he's the emperor he's the king he's in
charge
now he finds out he's not and he's found
that out you know in a few bits and
pieces the chris doyle situation he
found out he just can't ram through
whatever he wants to do there's going to
be public pushback
now he's finding out you can't ram
through whatever offseason program you
want
there's going to be pushback from the
league and the union and he's learned a
very expensive lesson
and i think that we need to be paying
attention to that as the season unfolds
we'll probably hear stories about
extra physical practices meyer pushing
the limit
a lot of the stuff that happens at
colleges that we don't really find out
about
how aggressive and intense their
practices are year round
that's what meyer is bringing into town
it just shows you
spring for spring practice must be
grueling for college players
because for meyer what happened i assume
was normal and maybe it was even a
scaled down version of normal and he
still got fined 100 grand
and the team 200 grand so i'm surprised
more teams weren't punished this year
but the league in the unit being very
aggressive and for the other two teams
i can see why they're maybe pushing the
envelope mike mccarthy's feeling the
heat in dallas trying to instill a new
sense of toughness especially on the
defense
and and for the 49ers i just think kyle
shanahan's exasperated generally about
everything and he feels a sense of
urgency and he wants to get his team
ready to go and he maybe wants to put
an extra callus on their bodies in the
off-season to reduce the injuries that
popped up last year and derailed what
could have been a potential super bowl
run something else i saw today that
caught my eye
because i recall vividly the
conversation sims and i had on pft live
when tom brady of all people spoke out
against players participating in
voluntary offseason workouts the same
tom brady
who last year was told by the union
don't gather your teammates and work out
together
until training camp opens because of the
pandemic and brady gave the double
barrel middle finger to the union and
did it anyway
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself remember that on instagram
got these guys together got his work in
this year
he's in favor of players staying away
troy aikman
on the flying coach podcast pointing out
that
he thinks brady did it and this is sims
and i laughed about at the time
aikman believes brady took that position
for competitive purposes
he wants all the other teams to have
their players
stay away and otherwise not work out
while brady and his guys
stay away but not really away they were
working out on their own
one building over in tampa they got
their work
in aikman's theory is brady wants
everyone else to not get their work in
because he knows he's getting his work
in
competitive advantage and when sims and
i
said it we were kind of joking and look
i don't know whether aikman's going to
come out and say he was joking or his
words were taken out of context or
whatever would be the first time
frankly all due respect but uh
i think it's i think it's interesting i
think it's significant and it may be
dead on balls accurate as they say in my
cousin vinnie
can i say it on this i guess i can they
can always bleep it if they want to
anyway
aikman may be right on the money about
what brady's motivation was
last point before i take a look at
whether or not there's any questions to
answer today
reggie bush wants his heisman back
reggie bush wants his ncaa records
reinstated
and he's absolutely right one thing
we've learned through
the last 10 years and culminating in the
passage of the
ability the opening of the floodgates
for players to profit from their name
their image their likeness any money
that anyone got from anyone other than
the school
shouldn't have mattered but the ncaa had
to prop up this phony facade
of amateurism so they had to go after
anyone who was getting any money when he
can't get any money and where he can't
get any money kick he can't have this
can if he can't have a cookie
because they had to preserve the notion
that there's a purity of amateur
athleticism and that was all aimed
at and it still is aimed at keeping the
teams from having to pay their players
you get free labor that's what it's all
about well
now that the name image and likeness
cats out of the bag
yeah reggie bush should get his heisman
back and his record should be reinstated
the problem is he's not the only one
and i think the last thing the ncaa
wants to do is start sliding down this
rabbit hole
of making things right with players who
got screwed in the past because that
will only highlight
how corrupt the whole thing has been
and how corrupt it still is i'm hoping
that what happened yesterday
with these new rules allowing players to
get paid by others
isn't the end it's just the beginning
and i'm hoping within the next five
years there will be a model in place
that shares tv revenue
with the athletes that pays on a
competitive basis
based on whether alabama's going to pay
more or texas is going to pay more who's
going to pay more to get that player
these are grown
people they are 18 years old for the
most part or older
they should be getting paid fair value
for what they bring to the table
nil is a beginning and again i hope it's
very far from the end
we may be close to the end we may be far
from the end let's see if we got any
questions to answer today
not many people upper the pft pm posse
not an am crowd that's for sure
how about tom marshall when the nfl
expands to include an international
franchise do you think will be owned by
an american
that's an interesting question you know
there aren't enough people
in the world with the kind of money to
own an nfl team i suppose they would
prefer to have local internship
ownership
just so they don't get into the whole uh
set of issues we've seen with
outsiders owning soccer clubs
like stan kroenke and the glazers in
tampa
but uh i look at the end of the day
what will happen is there will be
if they expand cities that are targeted
and there will be groups in those cities
and how viable those ownership groups
are will go a long way toward
determining
whether or not those teams are the ones
that are selected
and i could see a hybrid with maybe
partial american and partial
england ownership of a team in london if
that happens
and keep this in mind i remember at some
point
i'd say it was about 10 years ago years
before the nfl was back in la
al michael said if the nfl ever takes
one team back it's taking two
and he was right i think if the nfl goes
to london
it's not going to be one team it's going
to be two so uh
that's coming and and i think there will
be some international component to
ownership but there may be some american
as well but the bottom line is
you need plenty of money to own and
operate an nfl team
uh let's see what else we have here jay
quintani if herschel walker didn't come
into the nfl with all that hype the babe
ruth of football couldn't an argument be
made that he's a hall of famer i haven't
researched his numbers anytime soon i've
never gotten the sense he's a hall of
famer he had
a surprising amount of longevity i i
don't and i don't
i don't know if he's even been close to
the list of semi-finalists or finalists
so i
i don't think he was hurt by the hype i
just think he was hurt by
the reality fittest and kane is this
upcoming
packers season a repeat of the 2019
patriots with obvious drama under the
surface
with a predestined split seems like an
easy example to predict what happens
with rogers and the packers no
and i agree with that you know people
think i don't want rogers to play for
the packers this year i want him to
i wanted him to be there if he's not
there what's the story if he's there
and he's making passive aggressive
comments and they have a game that goes
well or a game that doesn't go well and
everyone's going to be analyzing
what's aaron rodgers upset about i want
him there it makes
my business better and at the core i'm a
businessman i make no bones about it i
want interesting stories people say what
do you root for i root for interesting
stories
i want things that people are going to
want to go read i want them to have a
reason to come to my website
what's wrong with that now we're not
going to make up stories to make that
happen we get accused of making stuff
up sometimes like dude if i was going to
make stuff up it's going to be a hell of
a lot more interesting than this thing
you're accusing me of making up
i wait for the good stories i crave the
good stories i'm like the dog at the
window waiting for the owner to come
home
i want the good story the good story
here is roger
shows up and it's dysfunctional all year
long
and ultimately he plays well through the
dysfunction
wins the super bowl and as i've said
time and again like the ending of both
longest yard movies
picks up that football walks over to
mark murphy
and says stick this in your trophy case
and walks away
for good i should probably stop there i
like to stop behind though let me see if
there's anything else here i feel like
i'm giving short shrifts to some of the
people
who are asking questions
uh squash face if the leak did not take
place
let me try that again if the draft
excuse me if the draft did not take
place and players could choose how would
the league balance and manage certain
teams clearly being more attractive
destinations and others
for example everyone wanted to go to
tampa because they won the super bowl i
that's a great question squash face
because
this year who would want to go to tampa
they returned all 22 starters
see there's this this misguided sense
that if there was no draft all the
players would sign with the cowboys
or all the players would sign with the
rams or all the players would sign with
this team or all the players
no they're going to go where they think
they're going to play i remember there
was a time in college football
when games weren't on tv when there was
maybe
two a week that you saw and oklahoma
with barry switzer
could go out and recruit players six
deep at running back guys who would have
been stars elsewhere
they ended up there they ended up
sitting on the bench they ended up being
buried on the bench in oklahoma at a
powerhouse
that changed with all the games on tv
now you got 32 teams
and players will be smart about where
they go it's no different than what
happens with undrafted free agency
always say it's better to not be drafted
in round seven
or maybe even in round six and be able
to pick your team
because then you can pick the spot where
you're going to learn where you're going
to grow where you're going to play
who's going to want to go to tampa this
year who would they have found this year
once they signed back all those guys
who's going to go there
so i think that has a lot to do with it
it's not
it's a team isn't attractive because it
just won the super bowl a team is going
to be attractive for various
destinations
combination of money location and also
when and if the player
gets on the field and that's going to be
a huge deal are you going to go to
patrick homes if you're
a quarterback and sit on the bench with
the chiefs yeah i want to go to the
chiefs i want to play patrick my homes
well if you play quarterback you ain't
going to play
so uh those are all factors that would
go into it trust me
if they got rid of the draft and they
never will it would not nearly be the
nightmare
that people think it would be that's
just part of the brainwashing that's
been done
to make us all continue to think the
draft is the end-all be-all for the
building of an nfl team and as we've
seen time and again it's really not
the bad teams are bad for a reason and
one of the reasons they're bad
when they have high draft picks they
often screw them up
all right tony taylor important question
can't find pft on sky tv
are you guys on break last show i caught
was last friday
where have you gone well tony taylor if
you check us out on the website or on
youtube you can get these
hiatus versions of pft live and pftpm we
are back
august 9 after the olympics with a new
season
of weekday shows on sky sports unless
and until they pull the plug
let's see what else we have here
looking looking broner what's the word
on the dante adams extension nothing
yet no news yet uh if i'm
if i'm dante devante adams excuse me i
want to know who the quarterback is
going to be in 2021 before i sign up
otherwise maybe i just hit the market
next year um last question let me see
here so let me just see i think
i got more in here than i thought we
were going to get how about this
where is it dustin lowe miller how will
college
players being compensated affect the nfl
will players stay in school longer
i wrote something about this the other
day and i absolutely think that some
players will
it becomes a factor in the broader
decision-making process as to whether or
not you're going to stay
or go and now when you're deciding after
you have your three years of eligibility
in
one of the one of the positive factors
is
i can get paid marketing dollars to stay
in school and
you know when you think about the nfl
there really
isn't a huge group of guys that are
making a ton of marketing money a lot of
guys who have shoe deals
are just getting like merchandise and
shoes free they're not getting paid a
ton of money
i think that that for a lot of these
guys you're the big
fish in the not small pond but not
an nfl sized pond you may make more
money
that last year in college than you would
make your first year in the nfl
when you consider your salary if you're
let's say you're drafted around five or
six
your salary you're not going to get any
marketing dollars as a fifth or sixth
round draft pick but if you're the star
player
with a college town and you've got one
more year
and the anticipation's there it's going
to be a special season
you could you could cash in so i think
it will make
some players more likely to stay in
school it's just another factor that
needs to be
included in the overall analysis that's
about a half hour or so i think that's
good enough
we'll be back monday with more hiatus
edition pft live pftpm unless i have
some sort of
a complication over the weekend from my
vampire rogue wisdom tooth although i
doubt that will happen enjoy the weekend
stay safe be smart light fuse
and get away please we want everyone out
there
to emerge from the weekend with all
fingers toes
and any other vital appendages enjoy the
weekend and we'll see you on monday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports